welcome to this video play FM draw hot
chick Dragic who is that
I don't really see the name them okay so
we got a Sicilian the Smith moral gambit
hmm huh okay let's take it yeah and go
from them playing a solid liner I really
I really don't know any line in
particularly well so so this is this is
a pretty solid continuation yo how do
you play that I like to get in shape to
g5 is that possible some are like he and
Bishop g5 you probably will move the
Queen Raja but okay I have 90 76-54 as a
possibility yeah this kind of this kind
of structure should always give white
some compensation I mean it's may be
debatable of it is how great it is but
it's not like it's just a pawn down is
he definitely has some some play there
okay so he allowed this one
that's surprising the one issue is that
if he takes it I'm getting the default
square so this is the big issue of the
more I gambit that the default square is
weakened quite often interesting so he
probably will take with the f pong now
if I take only three hmm Jim it's hard
not to take her so let's do that knight
to e7 huh maybe I have to I have to try
it here try to write rate especially
getting rid of that knight on d5 is
certainly helpful
hmm yeah I don't know it's it looks a
little bit like he's running out of gas
IAM mmm yeah okay so Knight f6 huh okay
certainly right on f6 that night why is
there a better square somewhere I don't
know it's a useful move I cannot go rook
c8 unfortunately it's controlling that
one
I mean okay if he goes like age 4 i'm
playing I'm playing night h7 huh okay so
he doesn't mind dad how does he cover
the H pawn now we're not just going to
take it I mean okay can you Queen f2 or
something but it's not really what you
want to play
maybe a stew I mean yeah maybe he has to
do that hmm but what's now maybe here
and taking g pong and preparing for
Knight f6 and the possible whoopsie aid
Knight f6 g5 okay he can he s g six at
the end yeah Knight f6 g5 he has g six
at the end ha that's a problem
ha not clear but what what is what am I
supposed to do maybe rook c8 she takes
they have seven years walking into a
self pen as well well I'm not sure so
let's repeat once and reconsider Knight
f6 years not helping i think but i mean
i can't play the rules but he has Queen
at five back and hiss hiss is coming
from from them Queen d7 is not working
maybe you have to go d Fife you texting
okay let's go
might as well use this opportunity that
I'm covering d5 enough to play that it
takes it 95 am attacking age 43 n and
I'm currently blocking that diagonal
that also makes sense night XD fourth of
course also a threat sorry I think he
has to do something with capturing the
pawn don't really believe in g5 or stuff
like that should work
hmm ok so let's take him and okay
9 s6 back aqua Queenie 6 is also more
let's it's a pretty we had self in time
one not quite sure what to do Knight f6
is not helping in that position txtx
Queen g for tix tech system has g6 at
the end which is really irritating
I'm screwing this up here right what an
idiotic play from this fantastic
position not just a pawn for nothing it
was nothing I really don't know what
happens here and no time no time check
meeting would be nice rook to e1 almost
made but almost I still have the g rocky
one was made it was made in one you
played Roxy to a checkmate ah hey I
really didn't look at this move I was
just plain ah well I marry rusty here ya
hear this position is just fantastic for
like it should be I mean I absolutely
cannot believe that white shouldn't be
losing here after h form so night h7 and
what it's not that bad okay I mean I
mean I'm a notorious optimist but
computer just gives 0.64 like with a 5
and b5 okay I didn't consider that one
here what what I did is that bad I mean
like here and then d 5 no it isn't bad
but just 0.5 27 is correct and 93 I
didn't see that move okayed wins it wins
all ports and basically I mean that man
for the face so it's it's a sacrifice
but check winning a ton of pawns
minus one but ok it's not like he's just
um losing straight away ok and here
while I simply had to play moving a
change and you saw that this is
problematic but um yeah we have 7 Chen
and this isn't even that clear [ __ ] gives
b5 wow ok I had to head to play moose
and quickly Mia here I was hoping for
the maid and now he played played this
precise move it's like a help made to
allow me to checkmate him but well I
didn't expect expected look see one and
i was just dashing out this one and then
when he stepped again entered a mate so
yeah ok sometimes you better lucky than
good ok thanks for watching